prenez un instant pour réfléchir à un
moment où votre vie a complètement
basculé
j'ai vécu un de ces moments aussi un
moment on sait qu'une opportunité unique
se présentent à nous et qu'il faut
absolument la saisir je vous racontais
comment ma vie a basculé lorsque j'avais
21 ans
je suis né et j'ai vécu en roumanie
jusqu'à l'âge de 13 ans un jour mes
parents m'ont proposé de déménager à
barcelone je leur ai fait confiance et
je les ai suivis il faut dire qu'à
l'époque j'avais pas tellement le choix
je leur ai fait confiance à nouveau
lorsque trois ans plus tard ils m'ont
proposé d'intégrer un internat en suisse
à la fin de mon lycée c'est eux qui
m'ont fait confiance
lorsque je leur ai annoncé que j'allais
partir faire des études de pharmacie à
paris sud est au cours de ma troisième
année j'ai fait confiance à nouveau à
une de mes professeurs qui m'a proposé
de faire une école de commerce en
parallèle et c'est justement pendant un
de ses cours d'école de commerce que je
suis tombé un peu par hasard sur le
profil twitter de l'un de mes profs il
avait écrit dans sa bio expert en bloc
chain
j'avais déjà entendu ce mot mais j'avais
jamais compris ce que c'était donc par
curiosité forcément j'avais demandé de
m'expliquer ce qu'est la bloque chain et
là il m'a répondu si tu arrives à
comprendre par toi même
ça peut changer ta vie
ouais ça m'a fait sourire aussi sur le
coup mais finalement j'avais rien à
perdre à essayer
je lui ai fait confiance et maintenant
je suis devant vous aujourd'hui pour
partager ce que j'ai appris
première chose que j'ai apprise
forcément c'est ce que c'est qu'une blog
shane donc pour faire simple c'est une
technologie qu'on peut imaginer comment
registre sécurisé de transactions entre
plusieurs entités
cette technologie à des applications
dans pleins d'industries comme l'énergie
la finance les jeux vidéo mais
personnellement au regard de mes études
c'est plutôt les applications dans la
santé qui m'ont le plus intéressé et
j'ai plus exploré ces dernières années
la deuxième chose que j'ai apprise c'est
que la plupart des personnes ne
comprennent rien à la définition je
viens de donner
je vais donc essayer à nouveau de vous
expliquer la bloque kane par une autre
formule simple
reprenons la santé si la santé repose
sur la confiance et que la confiance se
matérialisent par la blog shane alors on
peut admettre que la santé a besoin de
la bloque chase facile sauf que la
troisième chose que j'ai apprise c'est
que la santé ne repose pas toujours sur
la confiance
par curiosité combien d'entre vous ici
font confiance par exemple à l'industrie
pharmaceutique où ça fait pas beaucoup
de monde
en réalité les études montrent que plus
de la moitié la population ne fait pas
confiance à l'industrie pharmaceutique
mais ne vous inquiétez pas on a une
solution quand on fait les études de
pharmacie
on nous apprend le cycle de vie du
médicament on nous explique qu'il existe
une chance sur dix mille pour qu'un
candidat médicament devienne un produit
commercialisé sur le marché
le processus qui mène de la recherche
aux essais pré cliniques aux essais
cliniques et enfin au marché dure en
moyenne 10 à 15 ans et coûte la
bagatelle de 1,5 milliard de dollars à
l'industrie
ils n'ont pas intérêt à se rater une des
étapes les plus importantes et les plus
critiques
c'est la phase des essais cliniques les
entreprises ont énormément de pression
pour produire des résultats positifs et
mettre sur le marché leurs médicaments
et pourtant malgré les efforts
considérables qui sont déployés pour
sécuriser cette étape tout ne se passe
pas systématiquement comme prévu
imprécisions données manquantes
discordance entre les registres papier
et numérique
les files sont malheureusement
nombreuses dans un système en pleine
transition mais les laboratoires le sait
il n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
c'est simple il est systématiquement
pointer du doigt des 15 candidats liés
au médicament a raison bien sûr mais
aussi parfois à tort parce que c'est
simple n'est-ce pas d'entretenir le
mythe du laboratoire qui ne cherchent
que le profit et même si clairement les
industriels ne sont pas irréprochables
c'est quand même bien plus difficile de
toujours essayer de comprendre la raison
quoi qu'il en soit le constat est simple
il y a une réelle rupture entre la
population et l'industrie une rupture de
confiance
la bloquer en est là pour redonner
confiance à l'utilisateur dans les
produits commercialisés par les labos
imaginez la bloquer comme un grand
registre sécurisée sur lequel on liste
des informations et bien sur ce registre
est un peu particulier déjà ce registre
est immuable c'est à dire que rien de ce
que j'ai écrit ci ne peut être modifié
ou supprimé ce registre est aussi
transparent c'est à dire qu'on peut tous
le dit et on peut s'assurer que les
informations étaient correctement
enregistrés enfin ce registre est aussi
très sûr parce que comme vous le voyez
les informations sont cryptés personne
n'y comprend rien alors dis comme ça et
même si c'est génial je suis sûr que
certains experts dans la salle sont en
train de se dire ça n'apportera rien par
rapport à d'autres technologies déjà
existantes et très performante et
franchement j'aurais tendance à être
d'accord avec vous sauf que là blog
shane un atout aucune autre technologie
ne possède la décentralisation dans une
blog shane
il n'y a pas d'identité centrale qui
contrôle les données tout est partagé
entre un grand nombre d'ordinateurs
si je veut modifier les informations sur
un ordinateur
je dois demander l'accord à tous les
autres ordinateurs
pour illustrer cela disons que je
représente l'ancienne façon de stocker
les données c'est à dire de manière
centralisée
j'ai les infos et je peux en faire ce
que je veux voyons maintenant ce qu'on
appelle un système décentralisé et là je
vais avoir besoin de votre aide
donc attention imaginez que je
représente un ordinateur et que chacun
d'entre vous dans la salle ici
représente un ordinateur également
maintenant je vais vous demander s'il
vous plaît de regarder sous votre siège
allez-y si dans le petit espace où votre
siège
alors certains chanceux ont retrouvé un
registre identique à celui que je
possède tout le monde a ce enregistre
tous les ordinateurs dans la salle sont
connectés c'est bon comme vous pouvez le
constater maintenant je ne suis plus la
seule à posséder les informations on a
tous les mêmes données
autrement dit il n'y a plus un
ordinateur central qui contrôle les
informations il y à une chaîne
d'ordinateurs qui partagent les mêmes
données
on a ce qu'on appelle une chaîne de
blocs
on a une loque chain et si je veut
modifier les informations sur mon
registre et ben c'est pas possible parce
que vous allez vous en rendre compte
un registre sera discordants pour amener
un changement il faudrait qu'on se
mettre tous d'accord et qu'on modifie
chacun nos registres respectifs
mais revenons à la santé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui le laboratoire gérer seul
les essais cliniques mais maintenant une
autre possibilité s'offre à nous on peut
enregistrer les résultats d'essai sur
une blog shane et dans le réseau
il n'y aura plus que le labo il y aura
aussi des centres de recherche des
agences réglementaires d'autres centres
participants et là tout est différent
parce qu'on a plus un laboratoire qui
est seul maître à bord on a une
multitude de parties prenantes qui vont
s'assurer du bon fonctionnement du
système et qui vont veiller à la
validité de l'information
le calcul est simple
combien d'entre vous préférez un système
centralisé avec une entité centrale qui
contrôle tout et combien préféré un
système décentralisé transparent où
chacun veille au bon comportement des
autres combien pour système centralisé
lever la main à quel citron combien pour
le système décentralisé l'excellent et
bien félicitations vous venez d'adopter
lev le chain les poussons la réflexion
un petit peu plus loin le laboratoire a
mis sur le marché son médicament en
ayant respecté toutes les procédures
maintenant ce médicament doit aller du
labo jusqu'à la pharmacie et une fille
née jusqu'au patient et là encore on est
obligé malgré nous de faire confiance à
des intermédiaires sur cette chaîne de
distribution du médicament qui vont
s'assurer qu'aucun médicaments de
contrefaçon n'est distribué la
contrefaçon c'est un problème majeur
dans les pays en voie de développement
où jusqu'à 30 % 30 % des médicaments
parfois peuvent être faux ça veut dire
que des patients meurent parce que les
médicaments qu'ils prennent sont
toxiques ou ne sont pas suffisamment
efficaces pour traiter leur maladie
l'utilisation de la blog kane sur la
chaîne de distribution d'un médicament
pourrait apporter une preuve irréfutable
que le produit est bien passé par chacun
des intermédiaires de confiance de cette
chaîne il a été produit par le bond labo
et sa distribution n'a pas été altéré le
patient un médicament qui provient de
sources sûres
là je viens vous donner deux exemples
parce qu'on n'a pas le temps d'en faire
plus mais il ya tellement d'autres
applications de la bloque chaînant santé
et c'est génial ça peut vraiment changer
les choses
le problème c'est que quand je vous dis
ça comme ça on a l'impression qu'il
suffit de la blood chine pour changer le
monde mais franchement c'est pas vrai
l'avs locked in ce n'est qu'un outil
pour l'implémenter il faut un réel
changement de paradigme il faut
redéfinir les priorités
ou plutôt replacer le patient au centre
des priorités
ce que la confiance du patient ça ça n'a
pas de prix
et maintenant je m'adresse à vous
laboratoires pharmaceutiques êtes vous
prêt à franchir le cap
mon père m'a toujours dit que le train
qui va changer le monde ne passe qu'une
fois et aujourd'hui je vous demande de
me faire confiance parce que le train
est là et il peut vraiment changer le
monde change et non rapport les uns avec
les autres changer notre société
c'est mon prof qui m'a tendu la main il
ya quelques années pour monter à bord de
ce train et j'ai eu raison de lui faire
confiance
maintenant c'est à moi de vous inviter à
bord pour un avenir où la technologie au
lieu de nous éloigner nous rapproche
faites moi confiance
merci
[Applaudissements]